[Music]
in daddy tears news oh no don't cry
submitted by looking forward to JK news
a man's story about the only time he
made his father cry inspires others to
share their stories what did he do what
he do beat his dad that's like the worst
thing that I could think of I made him
cry I made him cry and inspired everyone
they're like yeah take them in a stomach
and a tear came out of his eye a tumblr
user from China cool glasses dude he's
cute so he posted this is 5:34 yeah
great yeah he posted this on tumblr it
says I asked my dad if I ever made him
cry in front of me before because I
don't remember ever seeing him cry he
said once he told me that when I was
three years old he laid out a pen a
dollar and a toy of some sort in front
of me he wanted to see which one I would
pick I think that a lot of Chinese
people do that it represents what you'll
value most when you grow up like the pen
is intelligence money is well money and
the toy is fun he was just doing it out
of curiosity in boredom it was
interesting for him to see which one I'd
pick anyway he said that I just sat
there and stared at the items he sat
across from me and waited patiently
according to him I crawled towards them
he held his breath and I pushed
everything aside and went right into his
arms he didn't realize that he was one
of the choices and that was the first
and the only time I made him cry hashtag
I miss my pops
hashtag miss you dad that's how they
choose the next Dalai Lama they put
three objects out and they say pick one
yeah they try to find the reincarnated
all right and they're like they just put
the objects down and then if they pick
the special thing that was his object
then they go opt out babies reincarnate
like one in six like the laws of the
dice again I'm a cynical person I feel
bad because I know everyone wants to
feel good about this but the kid have
you ever known out was like a little kid
like like we have a little niece like
you half the time you tell her anything
she doesn't know what you're talking
about she just does her thing just like
the story Steve
there's the babies three years old but
kids their attention isn't always on
like the parents you know if this is
something that's really cool they're
gonna like oh I want that yeah a pen
right oh dollar bill which means nothing
to a kid boring paper boring as [ __ ] and
was the other one toy I mean was it not
one of his favorite toys what kind of
toys it to and what does the dad think a
toy is where the [ __ ] is your hearts the
yeah where is it Steve probably no it
was a [ __ ] paddle ball of the stick
thing or whatever the paddle ball that's
so fun not for a three-year-old kid they
don't know how to do it he just doesn't
know his own son cuz my three-year-old
nephew
I know exactly what would what he would
go for its cake she loves cake and if he
crawled over cake and hugged you then
you know that it's something real you
got to put things that really matter
we need more details about the toy this
dead read too much into the situation
what I thought you were the one thing
just love this story well in order for
them to make their case tip you guys
should do that with tyka put objects out
if he chooses the barbell he's gonna be
a weight lifter chooses the boxing glove
he's gonna be a fighter if he chooses
the microphone he's gonna be a comedian
do not put youtube as one of the choices
and do it now all he has literally no
idea what the [ __ ] you're talking yeah
wait did I imagine this or does he have
like a little baby
barbell toy I got the baby bar Bob
that's a rattle yeah we didn't get one
of our friends got from yeah you should
totally put that didn't we like you do
that claim of it I don't know what
happened to it I'm just gonna give them
only one choice and there's gonna be ten
just staff the money so he just gonna be
rich no matter what it is that's it
teaching value money no you gonna have
that kid who you know there was always
some three-year-old from some country
who's like super jacked yeah have you
seen that [ __ ] where they have like
[ __ ] ass something what is that
called yeah have you not seen that bunch
of viral videos yeah
baby fat there's this yeah there's a
specific enzyme that prevents them from
having baby fat yeah so they're just
walking check them negatively at all cuz
kids aren't supposed to really have you
all are jealous dude these kids get hot
early and you guys are pissed oh yeah
I'm jealous see didn't have to do
anything yeah what happens to them when
they're older
yeah I think they just stay that way
dude [ __ ] a lot of chicks instead Filipa
me or whatever his name is I am jealous
yeah he's like [ __ ] 45 years old
never in everyone would rather have sex
that's what he's probably that kid
that's like though he's raising but it's
an old reference I'm just saying he's
like 45 years old now and she just don't
want to [ __ ] on him Oh Brad Pitt Wales
okay Brad Pitt there you go David
Beckham come on there you go so many
more current create people you can
abroad make a better reference next time
thank you I love you what about Stefan
how about Ryan Gosling's - real - real
Mickey it's called JK news Nikki we're
supposed to be kidding wondering
proposing about carrot top I think that
matters all the [ __ ] Vegas ads you
ever see em is like the bottom of his
pants are always here and then there's
[ __ ] four veins popping up yeah why
cuz he injects heroin into it is
something oh yeah he's so angry yeah is
he
I care topic yeah is he really he's
angry I don't know that I thought you
did object work do pop comedy I have
inside take Ryan Gosling over carrot top
anything too real next next next real
new job new job Chris Pratt Chris Pratt
used to beat up jobs even when he was
touched I was like oh so Steve you know
hop on the treadmill a little bit that's
reference my body shaming
it works cuz it got me to lose weight
just kidding I refuse to lose weight now
I'm gonna go [ __ ] to Dairy Queen
after this [ __ ] good i love chub-chub
boys dammit
yeah either way you don't yeah so I
don't know how do you guys what do you
guys think about this story here have
you ever seen her dad's cry
oh it's important to note that he has an
Asian dad cuz that's I mean I feel like
we have an Asian dad no that's why I'm
saying he doesn't cry South Asian dads
cry more that's true I might as well
have Asian Dennis I saw my dad cry once
you have a military dad at one time yeah
the same thing when was that one time
you felt like that well actually I guess
recently he creditor with him yeah
that's that's what my dad cried too
Mitch I was actually really visible we
might like masculine like [ __ ] Idol
with the [ __ ] bill your dad where his
military uniform no no no no he just
married us is he married us though like
he was the he's appreciating it has
ballin like a [ __ ] boy is he like a
pastor he's very religious but he's not
a pastor
oh you but anybody can officiate income
you just have to apply for a life you
did know that
no but David is a pastor what no sir you
keep you know how he concept no he's a
pastor Boehner sure he went online he
paid a membership and that's how he got
it I'm gonna be a minister yeah you
should be all right no not a minister
you be the only minister who administers
a wedding holding a [ __ ] axe or
whatever what's the difference between a
minister a priest and the pastor is this
a beginning of a joke yeah it's a setup
for a joke
we're on the same wavelength right now
what is uh what's your job no no no it's
not I'm curious what did they get at the
bar finish it I really want to know
what's the punchline go why was it
pastors priests is Catholic pastors like
Christian I think a minister is which
one gets a [ __ ] I think priests pastors
ooh patrat the [ __ ] priests are usually
celibate
I think so that's the difference yeah
but what about ministers ministers is
the person with escalate in a purple
suit you know you know what we found out
actually since the Catholic Church
scandals they all get the [ __ ] that's
the joke there's the joke
we found it oh it's Christianity for
minister but so is pastors Minister
Bader
maybe maybe so much because I don't know
the differences and in a monk they don't
they have monks in the Catholic Church
it's a religious and what's a friar oh
come on
what's a friars in charge of tuxedos in
the French frys role what's the next one
it's about an emotional moment which our
Padre
what's a Padres translates to dad I
think father when my mom slapped my dad
he had a tear come out of his eye really
that's not you making him cry nah I
never made him cry yeah I probably I
probably did as a baby I don't remember
yeah oh yeah like every every week yeah
my was a little bit [ __ ] up so I made
him cry two times that I saw at least so
our whole life in our family he always
said like I don't care what you do in
life like just don't get a [ __ ]
tattoo okay so then at this point I'm
like what so you can be a prostitute you
can do any other I mean you know there
was born on walls and morals that we
stole like you can rob a bank don't get
no tattoo it's all 37 I got this one and
I show my dad and he goes that was me so
my dad's like very stone face like he
has zero emotion like that it looks like
one of those statues at the Galapagos
Islands I asked no emotions I didn't
want you to get it and I was like oh
[ __ ] you forgot no I just didn't think
he would cry yeah
this was no I was just like you'll get
over it and then he did and then I got
this one he's like that's it but that
was the first time I ever made so he
credit both your tattoos and those were
the only what was this attitude that he
was just like I don't like it or what
well because he comes from like a small
town or like his family and his
upbringing the small town the only
people that had tattoos at that time
were prostitutes criminals so when he
met Bart was he like
hello ah Bartholomew hmm see your house
and
no I don't think you cared really okay
that's not his son like ek+
and your agent so maybe that's you
that's your family so II don't mean that
I could be agent positive that's [ __ ]
up that's what Bill yeah my dad credit
our wedding like I was getting ready
like I was in my pajamas still like the
wedding dress was hanging and stuff and
he came to drop off breakfast burritos
to the hotel room and he just like
started breaking them to grind I don't
think I was supposed to show that sorry
dad no I think guys more likely to cry
like after 50 something maybe yeah
what's good we bottle in all their
emotions although more emotionally
intelligent so some of a lot of it now
just goes over our heads I think I know
that my dad suppressed a lot yeah
because he was a crybaby when he was a
kid and he would get like made fun of by
his siblings and like beat up for and
stuff and so like he just learned not to
cry mmm I cry almost once a week with
like that yeah what was the first time
you cried oh the first time I do it was
born I think I think a lot of it it's
like it's almost like a time machine
where like what's happening in the
present transports me also into the past
so I see tiger and I see like how much I
appreciate him and how precious he is to
me and on my man I love this guy so much
and then it immediately puts me back
when I'm a kid and I'm like the way that
my parents treated me I don't think they
love me the same way that I love like
them what is he crying about I thought
you're crying over how precious he is
but it's really just psychological
issues no parents didn't love him that
much compared to how he loves his kid
that's cream but then it also goes to it
comes back to how much I love him and
how beautiful this is
I [ __ ] love the [ __ ] out of you more
than my parents like not like my dad and
mom ever love me this much like is just
so they don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on he got his mouth open right
I don't know what love is I'm hungry I
think it meant more those see my dad
crafter like not ever sing him great
yeah that's why the bottling in is
awesome yeah yeah it means something
when you get it after my wedding I
pulled my dad aside and I went clean
yourself up
[Laughter]
[Music]
Oh